[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from beautiful Staten Island New York
where I'm joined by Dominic Morano he's
the heir to the Prince Street pizza
throne home to the Soho Square and one
of the best new-school sliced joints in
all of New York City but today we're
doing something a little bit different
Dominic has invited us to his family
home so that we can do a good
old-fashioned home cook Neapolitan round
pie and then we're gonna deliver our
creation - perhaps our harshest critics
to date his family but first things
first Dominick you know there's a pizza
slice shop on every corner in New York
City why cook at home why not it makes
it fun for the family we all hang out
it's a good bonding experience and it's
also good to learn how to cook on your
own why I have to go pay somebody else
to make your food I don't trust other
people making my food sometimes you
can't see behind that wall you know
what's going on and it's just it's fun
to do it yourself sometimes what's the
law according to Dominic any dues any
don'ts at print Street pizza there's
about four command modules okay first
rule is you don't dad the pizza you
don't take a napkin and a second rule is
you don't use a fork and a knife it's
not a pasta it's not veal parmesan it's
a pizza usually by hand the third one
you want is for condiments you know nice
ranch blue cheese and ketchup mayo etc
what happens if he ask for condiments
the pizza guy Franco come in put the
money back on the can I tell you you'll
no come back here you'll know this is a
disgrace you'll know I come back at this
am i I'm an artist I'm not this pizza
man you don't do this taking it
seriously and the fourth commandment is
you have to fold it down the middle you
can't just eat it like that it's all the
cheese 1/4 Dom are we ready to jump in
here are you ready I'm ready let's do it
[Music]
so I can tell by the way we've staged
this set that we're starting with the
dough talk to me about dough what would
it do you can either buy it from the
store you can make it at home if you
want to make it at home
you got a mixer some flour some water a
couple other ingredients and you can
just do it that way but who asked for
that
it's a busy day this is New York it's
fast so you can trust you can trust
store dough is what you're tellin ya
hundred percent they can they can't mess
it up I'm ready let's go down stomach
it's a pizza first things first you got
to take it from the sides make sure
they're not hitting nothing so now
you're gonna pull this fast see it's
nice and round love it
you take your flour just easily not too
hard not too slow if you'll want to put
any holes in you don't want you to put
any holes in oh you monster thrown in
the garbage don't you wanna give it a
try yeah yeah yeah alright so watch me
separate you can't have them touching I
learned that from my buddy Dom there you
go come on you got it that was that
pretty good I'll go through the top from
the front and then you're all ready lift
it off now usually now even everything
out you pull it out boom put it right
here so now you take my flour just get a
little bit around your area spread it
out nice make a little bit of a mess
yeah go go nuts that's why why don't you
ask flying why we're not in the store if
you want because the ovens a little bit
smaller at home if people buy a whole
pizza you actually ought to cut it to
make a little bit smaller for it to fit
in the oven oh you're attractive I'll
give it a try I'm nervous about this one
don't be nervous just don't make it too
small no you don't go go go go ahead
you're doing good you don't keep up
you're going BAM now if you want we put
C's decides what makes that please later
[Music]
give your hands up a little bit of heart
and just stop pressing down easily
don't dab at it don't push down just
easily put your fingers now palm it
basically all you're gonna do is just
you're gonna move it this way just
counterclockwise just wax on wax off
literally it's legitimately the same is
AG most relaxed on
hey though I feel like it's not going as
well as yours second I read that it's a
heart-shaped pedes
it's our that's what I'm going for it's
alright I love today down go come so now
we're gonna do is pick it up flop it on
your own now back and forth maybe once
what's always that's about it now do you
want how to spend yep you gonna bite
this know what you gonna do is you're
just gonna there you go it's been an
Smith it's just stay out of the middle
cuz you're gonna you're gonna Haines
gonna go right through it
take your beats like this and just flop
it right on it this you actually made it
a little bit better than mine mine's a
little bit too big for the panel uses a
good personal size you just learned the
biggest step of making pizza that was
the hardest part
the dough is the toughest dough is the
toughest part now we're gonna put the
sauce on all right working our way to
the other side of the kitchen for the
next step we have to make some sauce and
for the sauce stuff we have a very
special guest we do have a very special
guest it's my moment I'm here
you got me Mom I gotcha okay this is my
mother's home-cooked marinara sauce
here's time for my family from
generation to generation so if we mess
it up you gotta be you know you gotta be
honest I'm watching I can't don't make
sure we get this right I am a homemaker
get this right
alright so what's the first thing first
step we need all right boil put your
frame a little Maya hi Emma yes nice to
have is Carla grandma
yeah now do you want me to crush it or
you want my slice climate and then too
much garlic too little garlic to your
preference I like five what can be five
to a can you could even if you don't
like garlic you could fry it take it out
but you have the flavor of it in your
oil I put hot pepper flake only because
I like it a little spicy gives it that
little extra kick okay I see
[Music]
say one month but some people don't
believe in cooking with salt they were
afraid of it they honestly are but when
you eat there yeah a lot of pepper and
you eat their food and it's so bland oh
you could add the soul no the soul
brings out the flavor sometimes of the
tomato and the God it does important
stuff you can use a red wine and it
honestly enhances the flavor only a good
wine I don't use a cooking wine I use a
good wine that I would drink good right
now I'm just trying to mix all the
ingredients together just have some
continuity in the sauce just so it's all
even out once you get to a certain point
you just leave it on sim and then you
fine would you ever use jarred sauce on
your pizza
never never golf a bit I never never
there's no need for a jar sauce if
everybody just follows my recipe you'll
have moderniser all the time the nice
big scoop you're gonna put a rein in the
middle if you think that's nothing just
start spread and just go circular
circular see all those hunks of fresh
garlic in there that's that's how you
know it's real and those that's how you
know it's real going with a heaping
spoonful plop right in the middle and
then BAM and just gradually get bigger
with it just don't keep too much sauce
in the middle goes in your pizza okay
VIN
well did I put too much sauce on you can
never have too much sauce so for the
people making this at home how do you go
after the mozzarella you can make it
thin but then it's gonna somewhat
evaporate on the clients and a burn
really fast
so you want a little bit chunkier it's
just so it doesn't burn as quick cuz
it'll burn on the top and then it's just
like eating chocolates nasty this is a
stick pepperoni that comes from prince
tree pizza ain't giving up the name cuz
if I give you the name you're probably
gonna make it out of this house now if
you want to learn a trick to do at home
that you really can't do in the store
cuz it kind of violate ethical
violations which we don't want just keep
it and open it up a little bit
whoa it's a bit of wave action so
that'll faster it doesn't stick there
you go perfect
now just leave it at that hey gets in
your eye you get used to it so we're
ready to put the pizza in the oven but
before we get to that finish line what
are the people at home need to know what
you want to do is pre-heat your oven at
the highest temperature can go I put it
around 500 degrees if you haven't then
go to 550 that's beautiful
do it at that set the stones in there
for about an hour and a half so it heats
up a little bit and then put your peach
in there for about 10 minutes pop it out
and you good to go all right so we're
here at the dinner table the pies are
out and I don't mean to Pat myself on
the back too much here but out of the
oven I have to say I'm gonna damn
good-looking pizza but it really means
nothing unless it gets your cosign mom
so that's what we're gonna do what are
you thinking it for in a good-looking
pizza oh not saggy not flappy they put
me floppy you know I don't like pop no
no it's mostly passing small tests in
this smell pass in the eyeball eyeball
test you're a hundred Oh gross it's
amazing you're not just saying that no
I'm not need a thick skin I'm a thick
skin now go Staten Island on me I'm
still telling you there's no way you're
gonna believe it made us at home no way
and that's a good point because you know
people might be slightly intimidated by
it I know it pizza it's not the hardest
thing to making the world but you really
can at home body a restaurant as long as
you just keep it going keep it practice
and get the ingredients right get your
technique down and it doesn't have to
look perfect they followed my recipe
it's absolutely delicious well there you
have it it's the Prince Street pizza
Commandments now you know how to make
this beautiful meal at home and no more
excuses when it comes to eating sauce
out of a jar no more I don't want to
hear that
[Music]
mozzarella oh that hurt you that that
brought into your heart the way I said
that I have people online in the store I
wanted are like it's a mozzarella
mozzarella no it is it OH
what's it up mutti